we will now move on to the last part of
the basic modeling and simulation
tutorial in this part we'll deal with
the built-in components of system
modeler he already encountered some
built-in components in the last tutorial
he will take a bit more structure
structured approach and look at an
overview of how the components in system
modeler are structured we'll learn how
to browse for the components in the
class browser and we'll learn how to
search for them using the search field
once we've learned how to locate the
components we'll see how we can
understand the building components
better by accessing the component
documentation and by finding out how the
components have been used in other
models and how they have been used as
sub components in other components we'll
also learn how to put this knowledge to
the test by creating a model from
scratch using drag-and-drop lastly we
will go over how additional libraries
our additional component libraries can
be added to assist the modeler and how
these can be organized I'll go ahead and
open up a new session of system modeler
we will start by expanding the Metallica
standard library in the class browser
here you can see that it's simply
labeled as Meralco as he might have seen
previously this library consists of
different packages from different
domains such as the electrical domain
magnetic mechanical and so on when you
open up one of these packages let's
expand the mechanics packages for
instance you'll see that it's further
subdivided into sub
catches the mechanics library for
instance expand further into a 3d
mechanical library or a one-dimensional
rotational library and a one-dimensional
translational library if you hover over
these packages you'll see a description
of what they contain this is jus from
the top-level packages as well going
down further one level you'll find some
additional divisions you'll find
packages that contain a collection of
runnable example models these often a
good way to understand how components
should be used further you'll find
different building blocks that you need
to create models within a certain type
of domain in this case a one-dimensional
mechanical system the component package
contains masses Springs dampeners and
other things you need for this blow that
we have the sensor package these are
typically components that will read a
certain state in the model the position
of something the relative speed between
two parts and so on and convert it into
real valued signal while sister model
allows you to access every single
variable in your model off the
simulation using a sensor is a good way
to highlight the most important signals
it can also be used for feedback loops
and to to mimic real-world sensors such
as a speedometer the sources sub package
provides you with different ways to
interact with your models for example
you can set the position of a mechanical
part according to some input signal or
apply a force and so on the interface
package contains the parts needed to
build your own mechanical components or
whatever sub-layer you
looking at building your uncle aunt is
beyond the scope of this tutorial so we
want to be exploring it here looking at
the other packages available you'll see
that the general structure is present in
most of them some have additional
packages such as the media library here
for example in the thermal fluid heat
flow library but most have the examples
the components the sensors the sources
the interface since components might be
distributed across multiple packages if
you one want to find something in
particular a good way could be to search
for it say that we want to find a spring
we can type it in the search bar in the
class browser
turns out built into system ola there
are a lot of different types of springs
we can now narrow down the search by
using wildcards if we for example know
we're looking for a one-dimensional
spring we can start by typing in
translational to indicate the
translational library we were looking at
previously then we can use an asterisk
to indicate a wild-card search followed
by spring we found two types of spring
components here say we want to know more
about how we should use the spring where
it's selected in the class browser press
f1 on your keyboard to bring up the
documentation for the component I'll
scroll in a bit here for your benefit by
holding down ctrl on my keyboard and
using the scroll wheel
here you will find information on how to
use the component for example this
suggests that the spring should be put
between two sliding masses or between a
sliding mass and a a so-called fixed
component you can see descriptions of
the connectors on the component you can
also see descriptions of the different
parameters that you can set in the model
more importantly you will also find
cases where this class is used as a
component in other example models by
expanding the use in examples tab these
models will give you an understanding
for how the spring can be used
you'll also find other components where
the spring is used as a sub component
here you can see it as a part of a more
general three-dimensional spring click
on one on the models and you will enter
the model documentation
to view the diagram of the model click
the model name in the navigation bar the
model will open in the diagram view of
model Santa here we can locate the
spring in the diagram using the
information we've gathered so far I'll
create a simple model using the spring
first I'll switch back to the model I
had from the start then I'll drag the
spring into the diagram view of the
model
then I'll expand the translational
package again and add a fixed component
and a sliding mass and connect them all
together to make the model a bit more
interesting we can add something that
pushes on the mass like it did in this
pool with preload that we accessed from
the documentation let's bring that back
up again I can double click in a diagram
view to fit it to the window he we can
see a force component that pushes on the
sliding mass let's mimic that in our
model if you recall from the
introduction this force component will
be found in the sources sub package we
have a few different sources to choose
from here I'll drag the source that
creates a pushing force upon the sliding
mass into the diagram now how should we
connect this component say we want to
push the mass into the spring just as
you open the documentation from the
class browser you can open the
documentation by selecting the component
in the diagram view and pressing f1
let's look at the documentation for the
mass component and I'll scroll in here
again to make it easier to read here it
will tell us about the sign Convention
for this component a positive force at
the flange called flange a that's the
filled green square will move the mass
in a positive direction and a negative
force will move it in the negative
direction the same is true for flange B
so we could either connect tech force
component like this or like this in my
case I'll go with the ladder since it
makes a bit more visual sense in terms
of the simulation it makes no difference
now it looks like we need to connect
something to the left side of the force
component this connector is a bit
different from the others and if we try
to connect it to one of our green
connectors model Center won't let us do
that the connectors are incompatible
again we can look at the documentation
look at the documentation for the force
component you'll see that the input
signal F can be provided from one on the
signal generator blocks of the model
again blocks dot sources sub package the
blue arrow is what indicates that this
is a real-valued signal as you do more
modeling you will learn to recognize the
different types of connectors and where
the components are usually found a quick
summary can be seen here we can now go
into the blocks dot sources library as
suggested we could use a step component
here it can provide us with an initial
negative force that pushes the sliding
mass into the spring and then sets the
force to zero to let go of the sliding
mass we need to set a few parameters do
this some documentation x' such as the
step block will have descriptive images
that show you how different parameters
affect the component here you can see
that offset will be the initial force
before the step the height is the step
height and the start time is when the
step happens
if want to have a negative force that
disappears of the step we'll set a
negative force as the offset value and
then set the height to be an equally
large positive value so if we set the
offset to be minus one and the height to
be one and we'll set the start time to
be for example five then we'll have an
initial force that pushes the mass into
the spring and then let's go after five
seconds you can now simulate and explore
the model that you just created see the
extra assignments in that touch notebook
to get more information about with this
model now let's look at what you can do
if the domain you're interested in
modeling is not included in the
Metallica standard library additional
libraries can be installed into system
modeler these can be found on the
library store on the system on the
website one way to access the library
store is to go to documentation and
click on additional libraries then click
find additional libraries here you'll
see some extra libraries from any
different domain many which are free go
to one of the libraries to read more
about it you'll find the description of
the library video tutorial showing you
how it can be used and examples from
modeling within that particular domain
click the download button to download a
free copy once the file has been
downloaded you can double click it to
install the library system modeler
alternatively you can drag it in to your
current system modular session you'll be
prompted to install the library click on
install library to install it
the documentation for the newly
installed library will appear
you'll find all the new components
associated with library in the libraries
tab of system modular 2 manager
installed libraries go to tools and
click on options then select Mullica
libraries here you can see all your
installed libraries you can right click
it to uninstall it
you can also deselect it so that we
won't get loaded
together with system modeler you can
also add custom library paths to load
model occur packages upon start of
system Wadler that's the end of this
tutorial we recommend that you have a
look at the extra assignments in there
touch notebook as these will give you a
deeper understanding of using the
building components of system modeler
so let me quickly recap the content of
this tutorial here we've learned how to
fine the built-in components in system
modeler and we've learned how they are
organized we've also had a look at the
component documentation and how to find
out how components have been used in
other models using this knowledge we
built our own model from scratch using
drag-and-drop then we had a look at the
system or the library store where new
domains can be added to system obler
such as the biochemical domain thank you
for watching this tutorial we'll open it
up for questions from the from the
attendees now